when so far as possible I think we would
benefit from exiting that statutory
regime very controlled and rigid and
top-down towards the more flexible open
spontaneous system we'd get with the
common law hi I'm Todd crane here for a
reason TV I'm here with Tom W Bell
professor of law at Chapman University
and the author most recently of
intellectual privilege copyright common
law and the common good which is
published by the Merck ADA Center Tom
welcome to Reason TV Thank You Todd the
Constitution originally guarantees a
certain amount of copyright protection
right for 14 years and renewable for
another 14 years if I understand it
correctly what the Constitution itself
doesn't make provision for any
particular term but the first Copyright
Act passed just after the Constitution
was ratified in 1791 Aksum term of 28
years and and that has actually been
extended through the years to something
much more right the life of the creator
plus what another 70 to 95 years seventy
years yes yes a little perv corporate
works it could last for up to a hundred
and twenty years on one hand if the
intent of that was to privilege creators
right to make more things you could
argue that that's actually worked quite
spectacularly right we we live in a
world with all sorts of stuff more
photos more music than ever before just
to click away on the internet what in
your view is wrong with the current
system and why does it need to be
reformed I think there's a lot to say
for copyright today I certainly agree
there's a cornucopia of cultural
artifacts that we enjoy sure copyright
gets all the credit for that though and
I think in a lot of ways the success of
the Arts and all those you mentioned
photography music everything else shows
that we don't need more copyright and
probably we could dial it back and still
enjoy this great wealth of culture
that's been generated that's already in
our libraries so it's been a success yes
so we don't know all that success is
from copyright and it's some evidence we
don't need more copyright can you give
us an example of a case a specific
instance where copyright has actually
harmed the system harmed creators
producers I'm sure I can give you an
example of a woman created a book called
wind done gone it was another take on
Gone with the Wind told from a slave's
point of view and initially she faced an
injunction that shut her down because
the copyright holders of Gone with the
Wind viewed that as infringement now it
took some litigation eventually they got
worked out but that sort of thing scares
off people who want to reinterpret old
existing works in new ways so they're
trying to add to our understanding of
works of art and enrich our culture and
they have copyright used against them as
a bludgeon part of your argument is that
common law principles actually work
better than current copyright statutes
I'm wondering can you explain that a
little bit well by the common law I mean
fundamentally those few simple rules of
contract law property law and tort law
that kind of form the foundational
principles of our legal system they're
the backdrop against which legislators
pass laws and so copyright is in
contrast to the common law and my
argument in the book is we should try
and so far as possible to exit from that
special regime of copyright back to the
common law because I think if we just
have people using creative ways
contracts and property rights in the
form of say DRM tort rights things like
that we can get many of the boons of
copyright without all the statutory
failures we've seen in the statutory
process you've also written that your
goal is to get beyond the idea of
copyright and I it's interesting you you
write our our packet-switched society
relies on just a few simple rules based
on natural rights and implemented
through common law to define a protocol
universally just and locally fair and
then you invoke libertarian economists
like von Mises and Hayek
and to say that our society
spontaneously generates peace prosperity
the fruit of conscious action but not of
conscious design and I'm wondering but
what is the chief benefit then of
getting beyond copyright well I'm glad
you brought that up it's kind of an
abstract point but I think it'll
resonate with libertarians I analogize
the common law system to the
packet-switching that makes the internet
work so well and the same analogy
extended to copyright makes copyright
look like a circuit switching kind of
the old phone network now there's
advantages to bow
but I think too many people don't
appreciate sufficiently how the common
law can generate these wonderful things
unforeseeable things really things that
are hard for us to predict because it's
a more free flexible system so I think a
lot of the boons we get from copyright
we could get from the common law as well
we could have new works of art and the
dissemination of books and photos and
things if we didn't have copyright sort
of getting in the way it's a top-down
process comes out of Washington suffers
all the legislative failures that
legislation all these spaces and that's
in contrast to this bottom-up process a
spontaneous order we get from the common
law so insofar as possible I think we
would benefit from exiting that
statutory regime very controlled and
rigid and top-down towards a more
flexible open spontaneous system we'd
get with the common law you mentioned
that there are certain industries that
really aren't don't have any copyright
protection whatsoever like fashion for
example what would happen if we got rid
of it entirely I don't think anybody
knows for certain but I do think it's
instructive that perfumes jokes recipes
furniture design automobile designs the
list goes on and on none of those
industries have copyright protection and
there's no shortage of innovation I mean
do you lack for new perfumes I don't
know what to do with all the perfumes so
there's ways people find to make money
off their creativity in the absence of
copyright and maybe that would be true
in other areas as well if we gave it a
try but I'm not calling for abolishing
copyright because really I don't think
anybody can know it's more subtle than
that what I proposed I think we should
set up the system so that innovators
have an opportunity and an incentive to
try standing on their own feet as it
were in the common law system to maybe
once in awhile give up some of their
copyright privileges and try just using
the common law maybe we'd end up with
something even for books and photos like
what we see with regard to jokes and
recipes and perfumes so the book talks
about that it's a tricky thing to
implement but I do think that we could
do with less copyright I think it's
worth a try I don't want to strike opera
from the books I think it'd be a mistake
but I do would like to see reforms
towards the last copyright I wonder if
you could talk a little bit about why
you're here in DC Ben
on Capitol Hill for a while and what has
been your experience actually getting in
with legislators well you know it's
interesting if you had asked me a
question like that five years ago I
think I would have said oh it's gonna be
more of the same more copyright more
copyright more copyright because back
then there was just one lobby basically
it was you know the publisher is
Hollywood and there wasn't much on the
other side so politically we're
interesting and they were entering an
interesting area because of a couple
things one some of the tech giants in
Silicon Valley see the copyright gets in
their way you think of some body like
Google for example they're not always
big fans of copyright it prevents them
from making money and on the other side
we of that on that side of the fence
also we see the public finally starting
to open its eyes SOPA PIPA that debacle
burned a lot of legislators and they do
not want to face another SOPA PIPA that
was for them a real kick in the pants
they realized oh my gosh you know your
average everyday voter now realizes
copyright does influence them what could
Pete was putting up these Plata's send
an email to your representative if you
don't like this bill and man they got a
lot of email so now legislators are
finally starting to see that when they
ramp up copyright they also can
aggravate a lot of people there's two
sides to the debate now so there's hope
that at least the next time they touch
the Copyright Act it won't be just you
know tightening up the screws a little
more was your message well-received I
think that lawmakers are interested in
hearing other perspectives to their
credit you know I less what lawmakers
are supposed to do what comes out of
legislative process who knows but I
think more so than in recent history
they're willing to consider other
approaches to copyright they too have
the internet on their desks and I'm sure
they saw those black pages on Wikipedia
and so there's hope that we'll get a
more balanced approach to copyright in
future years all right and we'll leave
it there Tom Bell thank you very much
for talking with us Thank You Todd I'm
Todd crane in for a reason TV